Singer Lisa Marie Presley's cause of death
just revealed.
The 54-year-old died from complications from
a prior weight loss surgery.
The report says it was, quote, a smoul bowel
obstruction caused by scar tissue that developed
after a previous bariatric surgery years ago.
The manner of death is natural.
Joining us now is CNN chief medical correspondent
Dr. Sanjay Gupta.
Interested in what you have to say about this.
Hearing of someone dying of obstruction in
the small intestine, but this was apparently
a side effect of this kind of weight loss
surgery?
>> Right.
Parts of this story make a lot of sense, and
parts are a little bit more unusual.
What they are describing when they say that
there was a previous operation that led to
this, anytime someone has an operation on
the abdomen, inside the belly, you can develop
scar
[8:40:32 AM]
the belly, you can develop scar tissue.
It's called adhesionens.
Think of it like spiderwebs that develop and
they can constrict parts of the intestines.
This takes place over time.
Her previous operation was years ago.
Over time, it may actually compress parts
of the intestine to the point they about become
obstructed, strangelated.
They are blocked, essentially.
You are not getting food through and there
is not enough blood throw.
That happens.
We know that that can happen and sometimes
people with off and on pain for some time.
What is unusual, though, is it sounds like
maybe she had pain off and on, but the morning
of she was complaining of some pain and then
was found unresponsive at her home, taken
to the hospital where she subsequently died.
That was a very rapid time course.
That's a bit unusual.
Usually, if someone is in the hospital with
this sort of thing, they can even go back
in and operate, do something to relieve that
blockage, but she had progressed so far, sounds
[8:41:32 AM]
had progressed so far, sounds like, by the
time she got to the hospital that she passed
away.
So it can happen, but these blockages as with
result of scar tissue, but the idea that they
lead to death, especially that quickly, was
more unusual.
It's really sad, the situation that unfolded
there.
>> The report also listed therapeutic and
not dangerous levels of oxycontin.
Can medications like that play a role in something
like this?
>> It's interesting because I think when someone
dies quickly, you think did a medication lead
to that, did it interfere with their act to
breathe on their own.
That's not the case here, sounds like from
the report.
Two ways it might contribute though.
One is that what I just described earlier
could be painful.
And opioids, other medications can mask that
pain.
Someone may go to the hospital a little bit
later as a result.
The second thing is, opioids can also further
slow down your intestines.
So a blockage that was already unfolding could
have been made